all right check check there we go we're
riding we're riding we're riding Oh
sometimes sometimes life is such an
undertaking isn't it you know you have
those moments you'd be cruising you know
in your life feels good and you're
you're just wearing your life around
your neck like a you know just like a
fox like a fox fur and somebody's like
damn is that a fox around your neck and
you're like nah that's my life you know
I've got my life so tamed that it just
hangs around my neck like a fox
and then sometimes dude your life is
just a [ __ ] Fraggle
you know even in just an instant man you
can get just so just you know you can
get keyed up irrational fired up
frazzled Fraggle you can get that
Fraggle going I'm here in Shanghai man
this is Fraggle central I mean this
place you if I don't imagine everything
everything pick something okay that and
then a million other things and all of a
sudden everything happens at one time at
one time it's like the Big Bang but it's
all over and that's what's happened here
in Shanghai China but you got to seize
it
you just got to however it's coming in I
have to seize it you know I have to take
it you know it's life you know I have to
take it I just have to take it exactly
has it as it comes
I can't I can't adjust how it comes I
can only adjust how it's received
you know c'est la guerre baby and that
means that's French for so is c'est la
vie is life so his life of a silica is
so is war I don't know
[ __ ] the French bruh you know what I'm
saying I mean not a hundred percent
really [ __ ] him but also you know nobody
really likes him but uh let's go onward
[Music]
I ain't seen home in about a hundred
days almost your mama bleep for my
restless soul and now he made $1 night
spell but where it's going ain't kill me
yet I still get where I'm bound go
mm-hmm however it comes
[Music]
they can roll right gonna make wrong
feel right
[Music]
most all of my plans slip right through
my hand
me broken on
so it's coming if they'll spiral wasn't
our glance up slay that I'm about an
hour past minute
I should've put it down omona
but how
[Music]
good man and that's it right there I'm
making it that's what I'm doing tonight
here and right now whenever this is and
I'm coming to you from Shanghai China
baby think about it China China we're
fish they have you know where a lot of
fish hang out and people catch them you
know I got into China and and I came
here to do some shows and I get into
Shanghai it's nighttime and Shanghai
imagine you're in a pinball machine and
there are like 24 million balls in there
and you are exhausted and you want to
find something to eat
God in started walking around I couldn't
even there was too much going on there's
like there's they have you know older
people that look young and young that
you know they had a baby that looked
about I mean this baby might have been
86 this might have been an 86 year old
baby dude and he's carrying a bunch of
hay on his back and they have you know
people are on rickshaws people aren't
horseback people on each other's backs
you know one guy gave another guy a
couple dollars and he was riding him who
[ __ ] knows I guess however far the
guy could carry him you know that's uh
I've heard of uber this is like ubirr
like hey here's a dollar
you burr you know let's go this is where
I'm going [ __ ] giddy up it's just
it's magical here it's everything
imagine everything imagine everything
you've ever known and now imagine it's
right here it's China baby anything can
happen
someone and there's so many people like
somebody will sneeze and seven people
will fall out of their mouths and you're
like holy [ __ ] people are traveling via
sneeze now you know Gazoo family it's
just like that so many people so much
going on and we're staying right here
like in time scrums basically staying on
this place
called nanjing road and is basically
like in the it's yeah it's like The
Times Square of New York so it's
definitely like a touristy area to stay
in but man just so and they try to say
they have everything you ever wanted to
buy even [ __ ] that doesn't exist you
know you could get a you could get a
baby diaper that sorts coins like oh
that maybe just took a [ __ ]
Diddy yeah uh but it's about eleven
hundred nickels worth you know it's like
you could get you could get a you could
get mittens for a cat you know what I'm
saying what's he gonna do with that
except probably just feel trapped really
you know trapped you know feel like he's
in for little bitty traps I mean
anything you want here they got it it's
Shanghai baby
it's absolutely Shanghai they have ever
they could they have you can they have
you can get soap that will predict the
future imagine that you got to borrow
soap you shining up next thing you know
[ __ ] but our boy you got that crystal
ball action in your dome and you see
yourself maybe getting a job as a
wedding planner or event planner and you
never knew it before and all you did was
crack in to a bar of sunny suds
anything's happened they got it all all
man we took a train took a train over to
a place called shaman shall Shulman and
and the Train is nice and you going
through the countryside and you see I
can't even
they got all so many a buildings all
look exactly the same a lot of buildings
there's not there's no windows in them
there's no people
there's nothing and apparently like when
you buy a building here you can buy a
you buy the building that's it you buy
like the walls everything else you put
in and when you leave you can take it
all with you I'm talking everything and
you just see I mean thousands of
buildings like that just sitting off
into the countryside
no wasted space near Shanghai there's
not an inch of wasted space I mean if
you you know like every you know you'll
have a gymnasium then you'll have a
garden then you'll have a CIMMYT I
shouldn't see any cemeteries so they
must do cremation do they bro you're
dead you're not [ __ ] getting you're
not getting twelve square feet you're
out of your mind but it's just it's
amazing
yeah the train ride was beautiful I even
wrote some notes man just because
there's been so much going on and
there's everything outside there's
everything there's like there's ah you
know they got fancy businessmen come
here you know and they have did they
have sex tourism sex tourists people
come here looking for sex and do an
exotic sex you know and the kind of
stuff where you know I'm talking certain
to self sex you know I'm saying you'll
somebody will you know trapeze off the
side of a building just land on your
dick or land up in your crotch you know
I'm saying you can have a dude you know
backflip off of a [ __ ] you know you
can have it you can pay a dude forty
dollars backflip out of a treehouse and
landing you ass it's that kind of thing
it's just sheer magic and they have
everything you want they have flavor
they have edible socks dude you know I'm
saying so you wear your socks all day
next thing you know you break them
[ __ ] off throw them in the skillet
today oh that's [ __ ] foot bacon baby
cut two slices of that and you're in bed
and you're ready for the next day
nothing goes unused here man I realize
how wasteful I am you I saw a man pick
his nose okay and then feed it to a cat
and that is that is China in a nutshell
for me that's [ __ ] gets in there and
gets out of clean little freaking you
know that baby body orb you know that
little bug wah and then gave that [ __ ]
to a cat nothing is off-limits in China
you know I'm saying that's
fucking's that dude pulled a little baby
Salsbury [ __ ] a stake out of his
nostril and just fed it to a cat that's
I mean that's damn that's that cat
caviar when you drop in bug bugs into a
feline and that's China and I'm not
saying that to to denounce China or to
or to shame shame I'm saying that it's
just everything is of use there is no
waste here you see somebody spit out of
a window you see a thirsty person just
catch it in their mouth it's like that
it's teamwork to to the it's and it's
it's really teamwork it's teamwork to
the end everything is used you know
everything is used man it's um it's
remarkable and the people and I can't
tell if the people are rude or friendly
or shy or confused or they just don't
care you know I noticed as an American
sometimes we go places and uh I'm having
some water I noticed as Americans we go
places and we're so like like it's not
really about you know you know we're
just so worried about ourselves that if
someone doesn't interact if someone
doesn't interact with us it seems like
oh is you know is something wrong with
me do they not like me I think in China
they don't even [ __ ] think about us
they don't care you know they don't not
care but it's just they're living their
lives man they're just cruising you know
definitely its what is it it's just
baffling you know it's baffling dude but
they have everything here man they got a
hat they can spell check
imagine that dude imagine having a
[ __ ] hat on not being able to spell
but down today on [ __ ]
now you are John Irving now you are
anyone you want to be michael crichton
shel silverstein you know I'm saying the
giving tree' [ __ ] I got [ __ ] vowels
on my head I got constant it's [ __ ]
dripping off the back of my neck you got
a hat that can
spell check they have imagined every
product that's ever been you know we get
products in America that are made you
know and it's finished it's a finalized
product and it's all attached and all
the advertising dude they got [ __ ] here
they got a scarf that'll kill your
cousin imagine that you've got that
nasty R cousin because everybody got
that nasty cousin you know the kind of
cousin that will pick his nose show it
to a cat but then can have it for
himself you know I'm saying
he'll just bug up his own throat but now
they got a secret scarf and you give him
that thing you know for Christmas or
Hanukkah or for you know Botswana or
whatever Kwanzaa sorry you know you give
him that hitter you give him that [ __ ]
neck piece and he's wearing it for two
three weeks you know he's at the bar
he's [ __ ] you know doing whatever
nasty cousins do if you got a nasty
cousin you know what I'm saying he's
probably doing crazy [ __ ] like you know
paintin is you know maybe putting like
uh you know um but what a nasty cousin
do probably paintin racial slurs on his
legs and stuff and even in hidden have
him pants on but even just knowing that
under his pants he's got all these these
racial slurs under on his legs and what
what a nasty cousin do you know probably
you know when when a parent gives their
baby the bottle and the babies enjoying
the bottle in the other room the nasty
cousins sneak in and have a you know
have about maybe three ounces of that
milk and the baby's only got six ounces
and they got this nasty cousin in their
[ __ ] swigging down 50% of that leche
coming so now you give him that you give
him that scarf and he thinks it's you
know he thinks it's just a unique scarf
you know he thinks it's that [ __ ] just
tensile for your neck it's that it's
that that year-long tensile you know
it's a year-long tensile for your
[ __ ] neck but then put out suddenly
he's taking a walk and you got a button
at home that one button you press
that scarf just chokes a [ __ ]
around and that's the kind of [ __ ] they
have here in China man they got
everything you know they got everything
and I'm just trying to feel like how
they communicate they don't it seemed to
me and look this is all my perception
and my you know and I don't have 20/20
perception I got about maybe 17 20 so
but they don't it seem like they don't
communicate much between each other like
in America we're always we're luck you
know we're always coming in we're always
you know it seems like there's more
communication between us then there is
here here it's just this kind of group
thing that happens there's a line
there's a line for everything there's a
line where you you are in line basically
in China you get in line and then you
stay in line your whole life and then
you die and that's just how it is you
know and even when you die there's like
a line to get into heaven like you know
somebody could die son Ling you know
your boy son Lin could die here you know
give get bit by a venomous snake and uh
and next thing you know he dies but then
he comes back to life you know four
hours later because the line to get into
heaven was too long
you know reincarnation is backed up yeah
it's bottlenecking over there over at
the you know in the reincarnation portal
it's bumper-to-bumper you know the cops
are doing breathalyzers over there so
it's just uh what else is it like here
the food I mean because that's something
that we think about is very man they had
a dude on the train
someone the Train and you know were over
there and we're riding and this dude
opened up a sack of straight-up cat I
mean this had to be cat look here it
smelled like cat piss like somebody had
taken you know made sticks out of cat
piss them CP stackers brah you know it
seemed like it seemed like somebody had
found a way to make a just a long you
know just a long
face hitter out of some straight cat
piss you know a little bit of that
feline juice juice and uh and this man
I've never smelled anything so bad in my
life and do you go to light they have
all these packet like bro you could get
a [ __ ] gizzard you could get in the
neck of anything Boyd the Chinese Oh eat
the Chinese wheat when I was growing up
you know they had a lot of like a lot of
black my black friends would eat they'd
eat all kind of wild stuff you know hogs
head cheese and more you know they got
kind of you know a lot of cracklins and
things like that that to me were foreign
to me but mang the Chinese do but if you
if you got your appendix taken out
when you came to after the anesthesia at
the hospital they'd have a [ __ ]
across the room boy you know what I'm
saying some one of your little mandarin
amigos one of your little cantonese
comrades over there just slicing into
that thing you know like george costanza
into a snicker just plating he'd have
your appendix plate it up you get your
tonsils taken out somebody else is
getting a bowl of [ __ ] two chunk meat
soup because that's nothing is wasted
here and it man it happens fast you have
got to be this is not a city for the
week you have to it take because
anything can happen here man you see you
know it'll be 2 a.m. you're walking on
the street somebody rappelling off the
side of a building dude is that Batman
practice is that a burglary is that a
fireman who just put some anything you
don't and you don't know especially as
somebody that speaks English you can't
even ask anybody you know you can't even
ask anybody man so it's just I don't
kind of thinking how else to say it it's
just unbelievable all the guys that
brought me out
sent up productions I think they're
called si na Brian sue sue sue who I
think is how you say his last name he's
not even Asian that's
he's um he's an Amsterdam Ian and Mormon
and uh but it was great man just the
hospitality was beyond anything I mean
I'd come back here so many amazing
people came out you know I met this dude
this beautiful man as he makes waffles
out there and uh inshaa mom and they got
an island out there and this dude is out
there slinging waffles brah
you know I'm saying those are the
straight-up gridlocks pancakes baby and
this dude's out there you know this
dude's out there you know slinging them
[ __ ] griddle hitters and it just you
know so many people came out people saw
me on Rogen people that just nice people
a lot of people people that are here
teaching English that's the top thing it
seems like and man it was just you know
and they wanted to just tell me a little
bit about the culture and they were
grateful you know a lot of really really
great Americans are over here working
and and and I'm gonna take I'm gonna
think about them when I'm not here
because sometimes you know you know they
because when we're not around we need
people to think about us sometimes and
and it can be when we're not around
anywhere when we're not around our
family when we're not around our our
friends will not around our country you
know we want to know that people think
about us and I'm gonna think about those
people sometimes but yeah it was magical
it was magical and there's also I know I
felt a sense of like I didn't feel as
much a sense of like self-importance
here and I know I'm just rambling about
China but look I'm in dang China dude
and I wasn't here last week and now I am
here and it's all here it's about the
greater good there's more of a sense
like your family I feel like people are
more into their family means a lot to
them you know it seemed like people
their province you know where they're
NER their region very important to them
certain food people would say oh this is
from my area you know or this is food
from you know the Hunan Province you
know our this is food
people were just a lot of cultural pride
it feels more like you're part of like a
country like a thing here like Chinese
Chinese it's a thing and they are they
have so much history
these people have been here you know I'm
saying if you go if you read Adam and
Eve right and the Bible if you read if
you look back behind the Garden of Eden
there's a there's a million Chinese
people back there hanging out you know
it's like the timeline I mean China
these people have been around here and I
some part of me I what I felt some part
of me felt like they're from another
planet and not in a bad way they're not
that that just that they do it if
anybody and Joe Rogan was talking about
this if you have if you look at their
writing it looks very like hieroglyphs
it looks like something that I'll
somebody would come from far away and
make for us it's drawings and and it
just seems like secrets you know that
somebody is showing you their writing
well what's been I'm trying to think
what else has been fascinating here how
everything moves they'll have somebody
walking right they'll have somebody
riding a bike with a child sitting on
the back of the bike not in a seat just
like on the like on a tire cover and I'm
talking like a nine year old and the
parent will be riding the bike forward
the child would be sitting sideways with
their legs hanging right down by the
spokes on their phone completely
oblivious and completely trusting to the
parent that the parent is navigating a
busy street there are buses there are
motorcycles Vespas scooters there are
cars all of that going on all these
intersections all of it happening and
all of it flows without a hitch
it's it's unbelievable it's almost like
you're in a bloodstream
you're in a bloodstream and it's and it
is going no matter what it's about
what's important for everyone
we are moving forward so yeah it's more
import it's not like I'm important
that's what we have in America I feel
like I'm important
like I ' important but here it's about
importance the this is what's important
for most of us we all have to move
forward you know and I know a lot of
that sense you know you got that
communist style here but it doesn't feel
communist
it feels very capitalistic to me you
know PE I mean I've been a Helana and
that's how some Latino people say Havana
and I say Havana you don't say how
uh-huh you know sometimes you meet
somebody that pronounces something to
[ __ ] you know come on man
say it what it is you know people are
like I'm from Miami [ __ ] chief you're
from Miami [ __ ] okay and your parents
are paying your rent while you're over
there at the U of A over there to you at
the you though you you know I'm saying
people are like oh I'm from you know new
GRC [ __ ] you're from New Jersey you
know that you can't new here say it
sounds like a cheese you're from New
Jersey so it's uh you know it's just
yeah it's just more about what's
important here the greater good
everybody's moving forward there seem to
be some pride you know some Chinese
pride people definitely excited about
Americans you know there's that there's
excitements about Americans you know so
it's you know I'm trying to think of
what else what else I took a couple
notes here yeah and I use you know write
notes but there's just been dude it's so
much here it's so much going on you know
we went up in
tallest building in the world you know
got my lady friend out here so we went
up in the tallest building in the world
or the second tallest I don't know it
broke so high like you're looking you're
like in the clouds you can feel a cloud
go like wrapped around the building and
scoot off okay okay there you go
a cloud just right and then going and
then you're you know you can see
everything it's like you're above birds
it just and not a lot of birds man and
look and that's another thing nothing
goes unused here and I'm saying dude if
a bird lands here it's gonna get [ __ ]
up you know it's gonna be a soup you
know I'm saying this ain't a place for a
lot of bird like in America do birds
mill around think about that in America
birds are taking the day off
I saw a pigeon when Tom thought it was
dead dude it was [ __ ] on vacation
just laying in the [ __ ] Park like
what the [ __ ] you're on vacation you're
a pigeon dude Birds relics and birds
getting fat Birds complaining Birds
catching the flu in America
bird flu dude here bird a bird doesn't
have time to get sick they'll cut that
dove into a couple of [ __ ] steaks boy
you know I'm saying you'll have it
do you see somebody with a [ __ ] lip
full of flamengo jerky
it's nothing everything gets used here
we're moving forward as a group you know
there's no but you couldn't complain
here about a bunch of [ __ ] nobody gives
a [ __ ] there's a so many people we are
moving forward it's not about you know
you it's about us and you still see like
a sense of you know people aren't didn't
and these are all my perceptions and I
might be totally wrong this is just how
I feel and see in this brief experience
in Shanghai our Chung Chung height you
know I don't have you know I'm taking
little bits I'm not getting you know and
I wanted to get off into the countryside
man I had this you know we're on the
train and I had this idea of like
and you're on the training you see like
the man on the bike with the hat and the
the the thing going across his shoulders
and to a bucket on each like a
teeter-totter on him you know
a bucket of you know perfect balance
balance is key here man everything moves
in succession you can't even I couldn't
explain to you how so much happens in
and nothing it didn't I didn't see an
accident I didn't see him I didn't see
any panic even like that's the thing
they don't there's not a lot of panic
here there's this general sense that
everything is going to happen no matter
what but yeah it's just been fascinating
man everything's for sale you can get
anything you want here like I said you
know you can get a shirt that uh that
you know you can get a shirt that every
now and then will alum will kind of hug
you you feeling lonely put on that
[ __ ] tank top baby you know I'm
saying you feeling lonely put on that uh
put on that affectionate sweater and I'm
seeing you could eat anything you want
they got it here do you want extra
kneecaps dude they got him buddy get
them installed plastic surgery out the
yin-yang here you see a dude look like a
[ __ ] triceratops bruh he got his
cousin's [ __ ] you know he borrowed
you know he had a cousin that died in a
fire something took his femurs out and
[ __ ] got him installed and it was you
know straight out his dome there
anything you want six legs and you want
to [ __ ] silk you got it baby you're a
spider now you can [ __ ] dude anything
you want to happen can happen here they
got it all they got it all and it's just
it doesn't end it doesn't end it all
night and it's safe here's a thing so
safe bro I haven't felt this se the only
other city that I've felt this safe and
for me with Toronto Toronto you could
fall you could go to sleep in the middle
of the street in Toronto in the middle
of a busy street in downtown Toronto and
the cars would slow down as they went by
you quietly as to not wake you up
like that's how safe it is but you feel
safe here you feel like anything could
happen it's confusing you don't know
what people are saying people sound
angry a lot I don't know just just
fascinating yeah oh I noticed people
want to they want to engage with you
like you can feel them looking at you
but when you look at them they look away
and it feels like there's a secret in
the air like everybody like there's a
huge secret going on and you don't know
about it but the truth is there is no
secret it's just this it's just this
human kind of fog that just goes in and
out of the existence just like in and
out like like China is a lung and it's
just constantly just breathing and
expelling and breathing and expelling
this sense of mystery that's in the air
and it's it's fascinating it's
fascinating man if you haven't been to
Shanghai I recommend it if you're
watching on the youtubes this [ __ ] it
looks French as hell I'm sitting here
I'm in my hotel room and man these
people took care of us you know I got to
stay in just some beautiful here to
marry up I mean the first night I could
officer I went out on the street I
couldn't handle it there's children that
are awake at 2:00 a.m. and all the
little girls here they dress up their
the the young that their daughters
there's a lot of pride when they when
families take their daughters out and
they all let them dress up like
princesses so all the little girls are
princesses I mean you know like in
America sometimes you'll see a girl
dressed like a prince every little girl
you would see on the street here is is
dressed like a princess
and and and so that was kind of cute
because suddenly you you feel like
you're almost like in Disney World you
know there's this sense of
you know you can when you see children
all the children seem very happy and
that's a that that says a lot for a
culture you know when the children seem
to be you know very happy and they're
curious you can see the children be very
curious and looking at you and and
there's not a lot of white people here
look I thought there'd be a ton of white
people a lot of Europeans no black
people no joke I saw two there was one
girl I think Erin or Erika that came out
to one of the comedy shows as a comedian
and one other I saw a British black girl
that I believe is British but yeah just
different you know just like what just
you know fascinating very very very very
very fascinating
so what else skyscrapers everywhere you
can see a skyscraper anywhere you can
see a skyscraper anywhere and it's all
happening at once there's there's just
everything
there's absolutely every nothing is
wasted you know somebody could die
upstairs and two hours are serving ribs
downstairs and that's life you know it's
about the importance somebody's hungry
somebody died let's figure this out it's
about important you know not important
and I know that's kind of a [ __ ]
cheesy thing but whatever dude life's
cheesy bro life's cheesy dude open your
mouth son you alive open your mouth
taste your tongue what's that brah
Velveeta you know what's that
that shop chat-up what you got in your
mouth what you got in your mouth so here
I am here I've been this episode also is
brought to you by grey block pizza and
bronx-born pizza
one of them's in Los Angeles and one of
them is in Bend Oregon
this episode is also brought to you by
Ridge wallet Ridge wallet Ridge wallet
dot-com slash Theo th EO & Ridge wallet
has um
they got this imagine that imagine you
have something stuck on your ass right
and you have to take it off yeah and and
it's some and it's a wallet that's what
it is
you know and it's and it's nice to have
but at the same time you got this big
ass [ __ ] crazy ass wallet in there
you got pictures from the 8th grade you
got pictures you you know girls or guys
used to fake you got pictures of people
you never faked you know which is
awkward if you're still carrying
pictures from the 8th grade of chicks
you wanted to hook up with and you're in
your 30s now then that is that's not
nostalgia that's illegal bruh okay
empty this [ __ ] out or just get that
Ridge wallet that front pocket carry
it's bulletproof
it's some stain proof you can't stain it
because it's not made of cloth or
anything like that
it's that hard front pocket carry
minimalized minimalize your style put it
in the front pocket ridge wallet calm
slash Theo get that hitter what else man
we'll get into some calls man let's take
a few calls we got some brick calls we
got some fan lines stuff we're gonna go
over some things I'm happy I'm feeling
fortunate to get this episode off I want
to thank everybody on our patreon we had
a single mom that came out and Shanghai
and I'm gonna get a call from her when
I'm back in the u.s. I'm gonna get a
call this week on the line with her so
we can talk to her beautiful lady
beautiful lady two children one and
three years old two little girls and and
she took the time off to come out of we
got her tickets and took care of dinner
for her and a friend of hers and man it
was just magical it was magical to be a
part of this scene to come over here and
do stand-up probably say about 30% of
the people that came out were Chinese or
looked Chinese they could have been
white people that dyed their hair and
dyed their skin kind of light-colored I
don't want to you know accuse anybody of
being Chinese but yeah I went to an AAA
meeting you know we're not supposed to
maybe talk about that but I went to an
AAA meeting I have two years sober and
that is
oh maybe I'll get into that on this
episode I don't know maybe I'll get into
that next week man just so much so much
happening here and and thank you guys so
much for the listenership that Duncan
Trussell episode was crazy guys we have
some so we guess that I'm trying to get
in right now and if there's a look if
you want to go go hound some guests you
know I'm saying I'm trying to get a
Russell Brand to come in you know I'm
trying to get Amy Schumer's to come in
you know I'm trying to get uh you know
I'm trying to get who else mmm Oh Amanda
Knox you know what I'm saying that
French murderer but she didn't do it so
I'm trying to get every you know I'm
trying to get the dark arts and the and
the light art so I'm trying to get it
all to happen but if there's somebody
who wants to come on tell them send them
a message on social media say you need
to go you need to go on these days we
make happen what we want to happen you
know for so long especially in Hollywood
I had this idea I'm waiting for these
people to do this for me I'm waiting for
this I'm now I'm not doing that [ __ ]
anymore
I've been reaching out to you know
guests that I think are neat I want to
have come on you know and so I guess I
just I'm feeling empowered man I'm not
wasting this you notice that Chinese
infusion bra I'm infused dude I got that
green tea in me I'm fired up bra got
that Schezwan I got that Chevron in my
nuts bro my spine you know I'm saying
I'm spraying spice boy papaya papaya I
got mace in my special place dawg you
know what I'm saying and I haven't
masturbated honestly in about 11 days
I'm feeling good about that I'm keyed up
on my own seed right now you can
probably feel an Emmy look I don't even
know what time it is that's another
thing about China what time is it who
gives a [ __ ] bro keep it moving
keep it going are you doing something do
something you there's not one overweight
I mean there might not be food here but
it's not one overweight person here in
China not that overweight is everything
but there ain't nobody's nobody look if
you got some extra gristle hanging off
of yo yourself somebody will come by
[ __ ] knife and Grill that [ __ ] up you
can lose weight here but I swear that
one of the reasons they probably do a
lot of plastic surgery is they're
probably cooking a lot of that [ __ ] you
know I'm saying they could probably trim
my nose down a little bit and have a
couple little you know at least make one
scallop they could pull at least one
scallop out a Muhsin out for somebody
but we had some calls that came in I'm
happy to be here with you guys this is
this past weekend I'm gonna be in
Raleigh North Carolina this weekend if
you know somebody in North Carolina
haven't come out what are they doing
nothing let's change it let's change
that [ __ ] together you know so we can
have them come out and I'm gonna be
there in Raleigh North Carolina where
else I'll be coming up Minneapolis
Minnesota at the Skyway theater Chicago
Illinois and that's selling out pretty
quick August 16th through the 18th
Zanies in Nashville September 14th and
3rd and 15th and then just for laughs in
Toronto going get those tickets and come
on and get those hitters and let them
know you got to fill on out there who
you want to see Ghostbusters man I feel
excited today man sometimes I get scared
I get nervous when I feel excited you
know I feel like I get nervous to feel
good you know I feel like I haven't
feeling like this a lot recently man I'm
feeling like you know cuz I've been
working hard in this in this you know
him and stand up for a long time and
like even in the past couple weeks
things have been going better you know
things have just been having better
opportunities and and I just get nervous
you know and it's not like I don't know
man it's like sometimes you just got to
put on that jacket of I'm I can do this
because nobody knows if you can or can't
nobody knows if you can or can't do
something and you let him know that you
let him know they don't just know I used
to think that everybody in the world was
thinking how he can't do it he can't do
it and that fueled me it fueled me
because it was like this chip
on my shoulder but it was but in the end
it's like if I show up and I can I don't
leave the judgment up to them I don't
let them decide if they think I can I
think I can I can and man I don't know
what I maybe I'm infected by malum I
might be Chinese man you know and I got
some Chinese features bro I got some
Chinese features man I got high blood
pressure you know I got kind of lean
eyes my eyes are real lean in the
sockets man they used to make funny when
I was young actually but man it's a
blessing to be here it's a blessing to
be here in China and I would recommend
it if you have consider coming then I
would say continue to consider that you
can get all tickets at Theo van comm /
tour we got some new gang gang shirts
coming out this week you can get all
that Theo van comm slash store and I
hate saying my name bro Theo VII it's
just let's just let's go to some calls
man you can always hit the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three or you can hit the fan line and
those are our live rays fan line video
questions you can submit a video
question and we got a gang of those
today - we're going to get into them
here we go on a call that came in here
we go and I haven't heard any of these
yet this one says Theo's old friend
let's hear who it is
all right and that's just me not having
the volume on onward what up dude it's
crumble thank you
alright and let's see her who it is
alright and let's hear who it is what up
dude its krummel hey talking a long time
man Oh crummy crumb boy my boy Robert
Krummel and this guy I knew this
gentleman in high school man old crumb
dick my buddy called him crumb dick all
the time and no real reason he didn't
really have small pieces of food on his
dick or anything like that his last name
was crumble and so just crumb dick
people would call him that
and he's not a bad person not a dick
people it was just like a nickname you
know I'm gonna saying everybody got that
nickname like we had a dude that had
been in a fire people call him Sparky
bruh you know what I'm saying
everybody's got that crazy nickname you
know we had a dude who uh we had a dude
they called him salty because he used if
he would get scabs and stuff he would um
after gym class when his body would be
real sweaty he would peel his scabs off
and eat them when they were salty and so
everybody has a nickname you know
everybody has something wild we had a
girl named TIFF and people thought it
was from Tiffany and I asked her mom one
day is it from Tiffany short for short
for Tiffany she said no TIFF like you
know you get in a little into a little
argument with someone I'm like that's an
insane reason to call somebody that so
but anyway go on kromm what's up baby
stumble across your website and he was
doing a podcast and I just gotta
remember in old days and [ __ ] and for
him to say what's up I know that was all
I'm gonna see how you doing man
at any rate I'm looking back to work
I'll talk to you later brother okay
there you go man I hadn't talked to
crummy right there I'm probably about 15
yes and uh and you probably could have
just hit me up on my regular phone
Robert but I mean that's interesting to
leave that on the hotline but hey that's
how it happens man that's how it happens
good to hear from you bud and I hope
he's going good down there we just have
this dude in our neighborhood also named
pug and he was straight up 1st of the
month
dude he used to listen to Bone Thugs and
harmony all the time and uh wake up and
and yeah and then one time somebody
invited him over to the house and and
everybody hit on the roof and shot BB
guns at him you know and that was on
Halloween and that was the kind of time
you could do that when you could shoot a
friend you know with a non deadly weapon
and that was Halloween style and we
would call pug over and then gunned him
down pop pop off the top of the roof
with BB guns with those small metal
hitters bro all right let's hit another
call here the hotline always is nine
eighty five six six four nine five zero
three I didn't tell you that caught that
the song at the beginning of the of the
episode was Bishop gun that was Bishop
gun again I know I keep going to them I
promise I'm gonna listen through the
songs we've had a lot of great
submissions here's the problem with
music people have submitted it can't be
copy written if it's copy written I
can't use so because they'll they'll
flag us and they'll take our episode
down here we go let's get another call
that came in hey Theo its Andrew from
Illinois what's up Andrew in Illinois
thanks for calling dude let's hear more
wait you saying your regret from not
serving in the military you know you
shouldn't feel like that
I served seven years in the Marines and
thank you for the year service man
Marines boy those boys don't play I
remember I was on some bases I'm doing
you know some some USO type comedy tours
and you know and all the services do
their thing but man the Marine boys show
up or women and they man I get at
danceOn Marines dude they'd like they're
like the Chinese brother they'll eat
each other if they have to you know I'm
saying you'll see three Marines walk off
for lunch two of them come back it's
like and the third one was oh it was
happy to sacrifice himself dude because
it's about that greater good let's hear
more and I just want to say you know
you're doing your part and you're
helping us out with coming back home to
a good country you know what I'm saying
like you're giving us laughter
and you know you helping out that
veteran friend with some money whenever
he needs it you know 22 of us are
killing ourselves every day 22 wow man
yeah you know and then as a you know
well thank you for saying some of those
things for one man I do realize that my
job is freedom of speech I mean my job
is a direct a direct freedom my job is a
direct freedom like you can't do my job
in some countries you know my job is
freedom of speech so people have
legitimately died specifically for not
for me but for my job for my ability to
orate to speak and to speak freely and
so you know I guess maybe that's why
some of that get feels heavier to me but
I'm sure a lot of men feel that way you
know you feel regret you feel regret you
feel like you weren't you know you
weren't strong enough or you weren't
good enough to do it but I appreciate
you saying that that we can find ways to
do it you can help a friend out you know
it's and that's such as that's such a
harrowing issue that there's so many
veterans are taking their own lives you
know there's a lot of issues there with
that you know there's a lot of issues
you know a lot of problem we aren't
getting the help that they need
there's a lot of people claiming PTSD
that don't have it and I'm not accusing
people but I may I've just heard too
many cases I've read too many articles
where it's like you know now everybody
just wants that easy right you know they
want that oh yeah PTSD sure you know let
me get that hit and not just and then
it's then it is it takes away from the
pool and the time and the resources that
are for men that are actually and women
that are suffering from it you know it's
like how do we figure all that out a lot
of the [ __ ] is just that people need to
there needs to be people need to want to
do stuff for themselves like one thing
I've noticed here man and this is
general speaking for sure is that
there's people seem excited about their
jobs it could be a shitty job somebody
has here but they're excited about it
people seem fired and maybe they're just
excited because I'm a white you know
they look at me and think of money you
know they look at me and think oh well
here's a tourist but there just seem to
be um I don't know America has this
malaise we have this infection that we
don't want to we don't I wonder
sometimes if a country gets so
comfortable sorry my emails on if a
country gets so comfortable does an
infection get intuitive comfort you know
comfort becomes such an infection
because we adapt you adapt and we've
almost adapted out of the pieces of us
that make being a human exciting you
know we've almost had adapted we've
almost gotten so comfortable sometimes
in America that we but that we've that
we that there's no I'm trying to think
of what it is it's like we don't care
about where I don't know I feel like I
almost know what I'm saying but then I
don't we've almost it's like we've it's
like it becomes an infection if you get
so comfortable then you don't you know
there's nothing else you just you lose
the vigor and it becomes an infection
and then generation a generation it goes
down you know it's like we need
something to really make us feel purpose
that's what I'm thinking you feel like
there's no per like I don't know China
feels like they have a purpose you know
there's this vibe in China that I hear
about that they feel like that that they
have inherited the torch of the
strongest country and they are excited
about that and they are moving forward
with that and it's it's all it's
pro-china here there's no [ __ ]
you come over there trying to make [ __ ]
you feel comfortable from a it's [ __ ]
China you you can't get a citizenship
here do you're from another country you
can't get citizenship here you can be
welcome you can be allowed to stay you
can be granted permissions but and this
is from what I've gathered you can't you
know I'm saying like everybody's all
like you know America sometimes wants to
be this [ __ ] turnstile and that's
fine but you got to organize that you
know everybody's [ __ ] stylin and
nobody's turning anymore
you know nobody we gotta have some sense
of order and this [ __ ] is about order
over here and and so there's you know I
don't know I mean obviously I'm [ __ ]
I've just turned into a Chinese person
totally giving up on my own country I'm
not saying that but it's definitely been
interesting and it makes me wonder I
don't know it just makes me think I
guess and feel let's hear the more this
call I'm sorry to keep interrupting your
brother so you know you're you're
looking out and you got his six man so
don't feel bad you know you're doing
your thing I just want to say you know I
appreciate the podcast you're doing
great things okay and going Gang Gang
baby boy gang gang and and yeah we
trying to move it on we're trying to
move it on but I appreciate you saying
that we had another call in here about
military a procedures saying that you
know that I'm trying to do something to
be a part of something you know wait
another call here about military here we
go they see oh this is to me I was
listening to your podcast about 29 year
old virgin and I had the positive in the
middle of the podcast leave this comment
for you what got me a little triggered
was your remark that dudes in the
military or more guys and ladies that
serve in the military their vote should
count some more I mean listen right and
that's a comment last week I said that
if you serve the military your vote
should count for more than if you
haven't and I got you triggered let me
hear more my vote should definitely
count some more because I'm a true
badass but unfortunately there's lots of
dummies that are in the military too and
they vote this way that way any other
way who the hell knows I worked with a
ton of them
they were completely [ __ ] I don't
know if I can say the r-word but I said
it anyway you can say it again it's okay
if you say it to a person that is
[ __ ] or around them or their family
I mean it's not going to go over well
and you're gonna suffer the
repercussions of it but you can say it
it's okay
ohm word and you know look they're just
people like everybody else it's a job we
do don't feel regret for not joining man
it just wasn't your pass you're doing
way better stuff now I sincerely mean
that I love your podcast dude I just
discovered you like maybe a week ago I
think you're hilarious dude you're now
one of my favorite comedians keep doing
what you're doing and you know I'll keep
doing what I'm doing all right brother
take it easy well it was a nice message
man and thanks for your service you know
and that's a nice thought from inside of
inside of a military mind you know that
they look at us and are grateful for
people that are you know that they don't
hold it against us I guess if we don't
serve in the military so thanks for
singing some of that man that's you know
cuz I forgot I think a lot of guys feel
like that you know I have a buddy that's
in there and he had a son I think he
just had a son about eight months ago
and and I got another friend over there
and lives in Virginia he's got two
daughters and he's in Moore he's a seal
and and you know he has to go away on
these trips and stuff and it just really
you know I can't imagine what that's
like and and the women who have to
support you know in whatever they are
the spouse who's not there who's not you
know going on these um you know when you
go out and fight or go out and serve I
don't know what they call it's like it's
not vacation and you know it's like a
fight it's like a vacation but you have
to fight and work so I don't know what
that's called
deployment sorry but but ya know and
just how you just leaving their family
just that separation that's a real thing
you know it's a real thing and
and I watched all my friends go through
that and it's it's intense and it's it's
intense and it's powerful to see the you
know they're wise both of them are guys
and to see their wives that stay home
and and really learn to be a wife and
you know learn to be a father and a
mother while they're going
it's fascinating man it's pretty
fascinating but uh but thanks for saying
that dude you know thanks for saying
that
and I get you know I yes so you're
saying there's a lot of idiots in there
they don't deserve it you know you know
what they're starting to do or what I'm
hearing about here first of all in China
they have facial recognition is coming
in hot they're gonna be able to know
everyone at wherever they are everyone
and you think oh really is it going to
be effective do [ __ ] here is effective
they have one app everybody uses
something called WeChat and they use it
for everything use it to text use it to
buy food you pay for your bill you order
food you order a taxi it's all in one
thing there's no a million hat there's
none of that [ __ ] you can't do Instagram
here I can do it through AT&T through
like a VPN or whatever but I can't
they don't have facebook you can't do it
through their Wi-Fi right so but they
are gonna have a thing soon where you
were gonna have like a score almost like
on black mirror that shows how you are
as a I guess as a person you know that's
gonna like evaluate you and sometimes I
think we need something like that in
America it's like so that way you know
if somebody is a [ __ ] slug and
they're not doing anything or not
pulling their weight you know and you
know if you are I guess it I guess it's
not more about knowing that somebody
else is it's just it's something that's
like we need something to light our fire
to you know we need like it's just like
it's hard to get a whole country to move
forward it's hard to go onward when you
have so many anchors that are just
stagnant it's like how do you fix a do
how do you remedy that when there's just
so many [ __ ] Muppets out there you
know just you know drinking each other's
breast milk for fun
yeah it's just how do you remedy that
how do you solve it you know it's like
and we can't help everybody we can help
most people I believe but I don't think
we can help everybody we have this thing
sometimes in Americus like now I guess
I'm thinking about America because I'm
not in it right now you know me I'll
step outside dude I'll talk about us and
I'll step right outside of the building
and point a finger at you you know so
that's what I'm doing right now and but
it's like we it's just like we're always
trying to help the lowest common
denominator and at us and people like
there should yeah how do you start to
know if people want to help themselves
because there's a lot of people that are
alive they don't even act like they want
to be it you know and what I'm saying is
dude if that's your case bro check on
out you know comes in to come to China
they do reincarnation here you know I'm
saying check yourself out you could be a
Bambi in an hour
you could be a toad you could be a UH
you know you could be anything you could
be a as you're off you could be whatever
you want but thanks for those calls man
it thinks those are our follow-up calls
from from last week about about military
should you know and I don't know if that
changes my thoughts really on should
admit you know there's just something
about the fact that if you serve to me
if there were a vote anyway I would be
willing to say well I think that those
people should be allowed to they've
earned a higher ability to vote higher
percentage of vote but then also think
if somebody graduated high school then
they should be able to maybe have a
higher percentage of vote you know it's
definitely but then maybe that that
maybe that I don't know enough to know
if that ruins the idea of democracy you
know I don't know enough let's hear
another call that came out of the
hotline here we go hey Theo this is
Dylan
I'm not hearing too okay Texas welding
on this gas right oh you up there
welding on a gas line bro well I'm not
smart but that does not sound wise dude
think about that you welding on a gas
line
brah yeah my homework but uh I'm
listening latest episode and a guy
called in who like getting his dick
sucked twice a day right oh yeah that
man called in he was a contractor he
said he spent in 1500 a week for
somebody to rock his [ __ ] around in her
mouth you know for somebody to frickin
uh vacuum up his bust busts kemon guy
that seemed like a lot of money to me it
seemed like an addiction to me that's me
judging him but that's what it seemed
like a little bit but let's hear more
he's paying for it so uh I wondered I
mean I agree with what you said seems
like it's working for him and it's
working for these ladies so I was
thinking you try not to masturbate yup
and I think I got 11 days right now man
and that's another reason why I'm
feeling nutty
you know I'm feat I feel like I got
pecans in my stomach boy cuz I got that
nut that thing is built up son you know
I'm saying I'll stare through a [ __ ]
peach right now I got that shine I got
the yin-yang inside of me boy my dick
will [ __ ] karate kick its way through
a [ __ ] week fence I could do
something right now brah you feel me
I'll pet a dog with my [ __ ] eyelashes
brah I haven't masturbated in 11 days
and not my Chi is like hey I get cheat
up boy they call me Chester cheeto bra
you know I'm saying I'm cheat I do don't
[ __ ] run through a village brah
I'll run through a village and lick
somebody's [ __ ] neck I'm fired up boy
cuz I got that nut I got that nudie
nudie bruh I got the Lords of garbanzo
beans [ __ ] just stacking up inside of
my [ __ ] nuts let's hear more and when
you're you're like masturbating with
them with their bodies right so you know
I thought that was interesting I
wondered what what why really if you
don't want to masturbate but uh it's
kind of the same thing he's doing
that he's paying money to have somebody
do it for him and maybe that's hard to
connect with actual people and quite
fine lovers and stop it here you know
getting good starts like today is insert
an awful lot but uh I just wonder why
you were down with that and I wonder you
know how that fit in with you try not to
jerk off or whatever so uh I love you
[ __ ] man keep your head up thank you man
thanks for the call but you know what I
think I'm okay with prostitution being
legal you know I'm okay
that doesn't mean I'm okay with sex
trafficking I'm not in any of that kind
of [ __ ] but I'm okay with prostitution
being legal I'm okay with it
I think that it serves a purpose I think
there are people that can do it in a
healthy mindset I think that you know
that I think it's okay now I don't think
addiction anything is super healthy and
I think we all find ways to check out so
we don't have to do stuff you know for
me with masturbation I haven't talked
about this in a while you know and I've
been struggling a lot man over the past
couple months with like you know I'll
get you know I'll be by myself at night
and I'll say I'll get this you know I'll
get this feeling like I want to do
something you know I want to do
something I don't know if it's bad or
here it is it's not that I want to do
something it's that I feel uncomfortable
and I don't want to feel uncomfortable
so I'll that uncomfort manifests it
wants to get out of my body and it's
like a vulture that just wants to jump
right out of my or just right out of my
heart and the vulture always wants to do
something bad you know and so I found
myself you know looking at escorts were
thinking about pornography and I haven't
been doing pornography but I'll be
thinking about it you know but then next
thing you know you know get to end up
down some wormhole and then I'm you know
I'm drawing pictures of or something or
you know I'm a man like um you know a
buddy of mine actually this is crazy
this dude
dude he used to make this little recipe
back in the day you know whenever we
would you know after we met some girls
and you know when you're young a girl
will let you touch her crotch and look
ladies I want to say this on behalf a
lot of the men out there thank you but
it starts to once you touch it after
that you don't really want to touch
anything else except more crotch and so
you're constantly men are constantly
nervous with their hands after that
because the only place they really want
to put their hand is in a crotch and
they can't do it because you can't just
run around just hide in your hands and
people's crotches you know what I'm
saying the saint's you know and just you
can you know your hand ain't
Punxsutawney Phil you can't say your
hand saw its shadow and then hid in a
woman's crotch that [ __ ] ain't gonna cut
it brought any gonna hold up in court
you're gonna go to jail and you probably
get your hands cut off here in China but
anyhow what I'm getting at here [ __ ]
what am I getting that was this hug
amount Oh hookers and masturbation so
yes I want to do some of my hands above
I can't remember what I was talking
about I'll go back in time something
will happen I want to do I want to yeah
you know like oh so women once you do
that then after that that's all we want
to do we want to touch more crotch so
anyway a buddy of mine he used to make
this recipe of like he had a couple
different ingredients I have to look
back and remember what it was and it
would smell like crotch and he would
take it you know a couple of these
ingredients and put them in a little
mixing bowl or whatever and put it in
the microwave or sometimes even put it
in the oven if he was making a little
bit of [ __ ] Christmas cooter you know
what I'm saying and it would smell like
crotch bro it was unbelievable I mean it
was really really neat because you don't
think somebody could just hype it just
do that
you know this man was like a perfume
he's like uh I mean that's the most
French thing I've ever heard of you know
firing up a batch of microwave was--a
but he would do it he would he would
create this thing and a head that you
know that stench because looking I know
this is vulgar but there's a you know
we're gutter
we are we are that is something that is
in us you know you wanna you know it's
it's it's well it is vulgar its innocent
but it's it's it it's what got us here
is that's you know the scent of of a
woman
the scent of of sex the scent of desire
the scent of of something that draws you
forward it to scent of anything it can
be you know it can be a flower it can be
any it's it's what draws you it's what
moves you and this man could make that
scent he could make that scent of uh of
crotch and he fire up a batch and we'd
[ __ ] just I mean we didn't hail so
much dude this one boy Jeffery passed
out and we're like damn Jeffery that
dude could end up being a damn Rock
pieced you know a rapist because if he
you know there's no reason to be
inhaling that fast with a little bit of
scent in the air and you can't even
[ __ ] keep your life in in line you
can't even keep you your act together
but do I see a difference between the
two that that man was doing that and he
was hiring hookers twice a day to blow
him
I see here's all if something if he's
calling me asking me if I think that's
an unhealthy behavior does he really
just want to ask himself and he's not
giving himself a an honest answer is he
just getting a second opinion does he
already know that it might not be and he
just wants to hear somebody else say it
you know here's the thing I feel like if
you can't stop something then it's an
unhealthy behavior that's what I think
if it controls you if you're not in
control dude and what the [ __ ] and I'm
not saying that at you brother I'm just
saying that you know that's when it's
unhealthy and for me you know
masturbation has not been and watching
pornography over the years has been an
unhealthy tool for me it started out
unhealthy you know it you know I got a
lot of it confused with you know where
my troubles still struggle these days is
you know if I get in love you know I
have problems with sex
because there's just a lot of confusion
in there there's a lot of uncomfort you
know in uh and so that's a place where I
still battle with and that's really you
know I mean I'm still seeing some
therapist about that and that's a place
where I still need to honestly to do a
lot of work in those areas and and it's
tough it's tough because you know what
the worst part is for me and I know you
didn't ask about a lot of this I don't
think but I'm just kind of rambling I
mean hell I'm in China dude so I can be
different over here if I want to or even
not even be different I don't know if I
am but uh but you know the hard part is
is wanting to do that work you know
wanting to get better when you know that
something is wrong and look if you guys
are saying look man if you jerk off once
in a while there's nothing wrong with
you that's true
but that's not what my thing is my thing
is that over the years I would look at
pornography and any time I had to
interact with a woman in a real scenario
a lot of times instead of doing that I
would just go masturbate or look at
pornography it would kill off the desire
to then go meet with a girl or take a
girl out on a date or do anything really
a lot of times and so then that became
just a unhealthy pattern for me and it
also was a protector because it's like
oh I don't have to go talk to it you
know I don't have to take any risk of
actually falling in love or any risk of
putting myself out there into it into
another person's heart because I'm gonna
kill that I'm gonna cut that risk
right off here at the pass at the
emotional [ __ ] pass I'm gonna cut
that risk off my shutting my [ __ ] by
physically stopping the desire because
your emotions they a lot of this your
emotions and your physicality of works
in conjunction you know I mean you know
your nuts are connected straight to your
heart and so you got a [ __ ] fine too
you know you got to be carefully you
can't be just be playing those harp
those chords all night you know you
can't be just busting some [ __ ] sea
flats on those nut heart strings you
you got to be careful and you got to
keep them tuned because otherwise you
can get caught up and that's why that's
where I've been and that's how a lot of
the dark arts started for me it was
being out there I appreciate your
calling having me think about this let's
go to one of our live rays fan line
questions you can submit those on live
rays get live rays the app is free it's
free to submit the fan lines and these
are videos so you can see these on
YouTube as well if you're watching on
YouTube subscribe hit the subscribe
button don't be a pervert man your
pervert your watching some dude on
YouTube and you're not subscribed
brother who the [ __ ] are you who the
[ __ ] are you let's hear it
thanks for calling in James from
Monterey that's John Steinbeck country
and John Steinbeck was up there [ __ ]
with anchovies and writing let's hear
more I'm a security guard and hell yeah
boy dude I used to have this sketch I
want to do about an insecurity guard and
it was just like oh he was just hiding
in the like hiding behind like a debt
you know like a like hiding in an alley
behind a dumpster just hoping nothing
bad was happening and in security guard
you get it okay that was stupid homework
hey I caught a fugitive that was wanted
by the federal marshals I was wondering
if you've done anything heroic that you
were really proud of gave me caught a
fugitive dude that's awesome a fugitive
sounds like pretty much the fanciest
criminal you can be some criminals are
like hey man I stole this I'm a thief
and some of them then have been then a
big dog rolls up and he goes you a thief
[ __ ] I'm a fugitive
oh [ __ ] Here Come a couple of fugitives
um have ever done anything heroic you
know what mice it when I had uh I found
two fingers in the woods one time when I
was young somebody cut off their fingers
here with um some you know with a sling
laid or with a cops I'm [ __ ] all the
cars I'm late
no with a I don't know a sword or
something I don't know
we found two fingers a peace sign me and
one of my buddies and we gave it to the
police that's not heroic one night I was
trying to get a [ __ ] from this girl
that was on the swim team and um and we
didn't say she was on the swim team
because she gave [ __ ] that'd be
funny you know if a girl gave you a
[ __ ] or even a guy and he like
swallowed all the time people are like
you know they're on the swim team Wow a
lot of bad jokes here in China tonight
but the thing was this the thing was
this oh so oh you know I heard you know
everybody heard that she gave [ __ ]
and that was the kind of dude as soon as
somebody gave one [ __ ]
you heard it I mean that was you know it
was like Paul Revere you know I mean it
was it was that kind of style so anyway
I took her out to this boat dock I
picked her up one night and I'd stolen
my mom's car and I went and picked her
up and man we were out there I put on
some Travis Tritt or something or some
you know maybe a little bit of a George
Strait or some just whatever the it was
they used to have this this thing on the
radio is called crying loving or leaving
and you would put it on the radio and
they would just play country music and
people could call in and make requests
anyhow me and this girl put on some
country music we're out there slow dance
and breath and we got the wind and we're
out by this huge boat launch it's like
um this was in Madisonville Louisiana
and they got this huge boat launch and
we're the only car out there and uh and
suddenly a car and we're out there slow
dance and doing this girl had some
[ __ ] hips on her bra she was built
like a [ __ ] barrel with small tits
and I'm just like man all I'm thinking
about David I'm so erect bra my dick is
climbing up my ribcage bra that thing
like I'm so erect my dick starts kind of
peeking out at the top of my shirt bra
that's how he erect I was brows fully
erect and that's when you you you could
get so erect your penis could be like 19
inches long sometimes you're like what
the [ __ ] if one of your legs would
disappear in just your
dick would just grow a foot at the top
of it he knows just crazy times being
young and she and our slow dancing and
suddenly a car goes across the parking
lot
right off the boat launch and it bounced
kind of on the water top and just ended
up out and uh [ __ ] is this audio popping
the whole time Jesus I don't know and it
just went it bounced off the water
because it was probably going about 40
miles an hour right off into the water
and then it sunk and it sunk probably
about 15 feet away from the shore so now
she and I and this is a huge parking lot
by a boat launch and she and I are the
only people out there there's not it's a
half mile to get to any anything there's
a bar about a half mile away so she and
I jump in my mom's car and ride across
the boat launch right across the parking
lot we pull up parked the car so the
headlights are facing out on the water
and you can see the car now is
completely submerged in the lake in the
lake pontchartrain
and so she and I run to the end of the
boat dock that's there and we got to get
in I mean this car is underwater you
know you can still see the headlights of
the car that went underwater or near the
top of the water but there's still a
couple feet down and they're still on
the headlights are still on so we're
scared man we're spooked you know we
spooked up you know we spooked up like a
couple of [ __ ] um you know like a
couple of uh like a couple of frogs you
know like a couple of frogs playing with
fireworks we're scared and and so we get
down to like our skivvies really we got
to get in this water and I'm like art
let's get in and she goes on the count
of three
and I'm thinking like the count of three
[ __ ] somebody's drowning you don't do
1 2 3 jump in the water on somebody
drowning you [ __ ] just jump in and
I'm saying the dumbest [ __ ] ever and
this girl was on the swim team this girl
was on the actual swim team not doing
[ __ ] and swallowing she was on the
actual swim team you know and she was
also doing [ __ ] but she was not
that's not why people said that she was
on the
actual team that had a group that went
to other places and swam against other
groups of people that wanted to swim and
so next thing you know she's like one
two I jump on three she doesn't jump now
I'm in the water by myself I'm swimming
over I get onto the car you know because
you can kind of get on to the now I'm
standing on the top of the car that
submerged underwater and I got to go
down I have to you know I go underwater
hold my breath go underwater the
driver's side window is as open I reach
in the car nobody's in the driver's seat
so I'm like [ __ ] you know somebody you
know they got knocked around or whatever
I go back up get another breath of air
go down again feel around in the
passenger seat and they had um they had
what I think and this might sound crazy
they had a ham somebody had a seasonal
ham right there you know what you could
get one of those big hams remember they
used to have that show supermarket sweep
and the thing you had to get was the
farmer John hams and things were xxx $32
and man you see you know you your
teammate would be running around and
this was a game show where two people
would go to a supermarket and they would
run around and get a bunch of [ __ ] into
a cart and they would get money for
doing it was the greatest game show ever
basically one of the greatest games ever
played next to maybe NFL football and
the teammate would always be at the
front by the register yelling get so
anyway in the passenger seat I swear to
god they had a farmer Jon Hamm right in
there and I touched that thing bro it
was this cold [ __ ] big ham and I
thought it was and and we wrote and
we're talking pitch black I'm underwater
it's nighttime it's nighttime it's 9:30
at night you know and all my but you
know like I'm scared my mommy wrecked
dude and you know you got some meat on
you if you were erect and possibly [ __ ]
possibly could be finding a dead body
and that was that young cat when you had
a young cat boy you'd be erect but you
could be [ __ ] digging graves and
staying erect and uh so anyway I touched
this ham or whatever it was and I think
it was definitely a ham and I got sick I
thought it was a body I thought it was a
shoulder I thought it was a head I
thought it was an ass cheek I thought it
was all of it I thought it was a big
huge knee that was swollen maybe
somebody broke their knee in the crash
and they had a huge swollen knee that
felt like a ham I thought all this [ __ ]
so I start vomiting just how to fear
just vomiting under water so now I come
back out of the water I get out I can't
hold my breath anymore to go back down
there's somebody in the car I get I swim
out I tell the girl you know who put her
clothes back on what the [ __ ] you're on
the swim team get so now we jump in my
mom's car right and I'm nervous because
the car seats getting all wet because
I'd still take him on his car she didn't
know I'm a driver's license I'm not
allowed to use her car and I drove up we
drove up we ran to a bar
they had a bar called T rivers and it
might still be there dude is a great
place to get [ __ ] pink I really in
the summer but you don't see that much
and that was a strong strand boy right
off that Tchefuncte River you catch pink
eye in the summer off the Tchefuncte
[ __ ] I mean I'm talking the kind of
pink eye that would make your [ __ ]
throat hurt you know that strong [ __ ]
and and anyway I go I ran inside the bar
I'd never been in there and I'm yelling
there's a car went off a gray car went
off into the water people come out of
the bar about four people in there
probably all alcoholics and because it
was not a night where anybody would
should be out drinking and they all got
in their cars and now they're all drunk
driving back up to the place everybody
gets out in the water now there's like
five people out in the water looking
somebody goes back in the car underwater
nobody's in there they say they don't
feel anybody I see
cop lights in the distance I get scared
me and my girl you know I'm saying that
swim team er we jump in my mom's car and
I take
and drop her off no [ __ ] and she
actually moved away she moved away to a
different state like about a month later
so that [ __ ] sucked
and it turned out somebody just did the
there was never a body in there somebody
had done it for insurance money they'd
like you know started the car earlier
and put a brick on it or whatever and
sent it off into the water
so so I was never a hero I was never a
hero and that [ __ ] cost me a blow job
there was somebody trying to catch on
insurance and those are the types of
people that are [ __ ] [ __ ] up in the
world you know those are the type of
people that say oh I'm poor you know
it's not a bad I important I'm gonna get
this surance money I'm gonna get this
hit I'm gonna fake this pts I'm gonna do
day I'm gonna do dit you know it's like
we need hitters we need we need people
that's moving forward but thank you for
calling on that fan line I stick another
fan line question from our library's fan
line here we go my question is why is it
hard for me why do I get so nervous when
I talk to very pretty girls very
attractive young ladies okay yeah I mean
why I don't know why you do but I know
why I did bruh because I put him on a
pedestal I didn't stand a chance with
him before I even walked up to them I
thought that just because they were
pretty that they were more than that as
well that they were everything you know
I'd always find the prettiest woman or
the woman that I always felt was the
prettiest since birds my mother you know
she left feelings of rejection inside of
me and I don't even know she did it on
purpose I don't think she did but those
feelings lived inside of my soul at a
deep level that I couldn't access and
that I still can't but inside of me that
made me feel that the woman that I felt
the cared for the most didn't want me or
didn't care for me so then when I put a
woman on a pedestal and that that woman
even just in just a moment becomes a
woman that I care for the most I can't
can't communicate with them you know I
feel rejected by them I feel negative I
feel because it was the same that
feeling that's when that feeling it's
inside of me that was left by my
relationship with my mother that's when
that thing kind of surfaces a little bit
because it's the only template I have is
that the woman that I thought was the
most beautiful and always would in my
soul my mother the one we all feel that
way about our mother if they if there's
rejection from them then for me this is
what I find and when I would put a woman
on a pedestal I would feel that
rejection again you know and I would not
be able to talk to him I would not be
able to have a voice because though the
woman that I cared for the most didn't
allow me to have a voice or didn't
didn't help me express myself and so
therefore women future women that I care
about I wouldn't be able to express
myself around so that's just for me man
for you I don't know it could be some of
that you sound like a caring guy you
know you called in here to think about
it with me so obviously you're caring
but I think approaching women first have
a friend don't think like I would be
like [ __ ] about to walk over and see if
this [ __ ] wants to be my wife
[ __ ] no you know it's pressure that is
for a woman don't even know and now some
man must Miriam is cuz they're pretty
that's crazy that's crazy and the last
thing I want to be around my whole life
is a miserable is a girl that's pretty
but it's miserable I don't give a [ __ ]
dude I don't care how pretty you are you
know I'm saying if you're so pretty but
that's all it is now that would be my
worst nightmare I only want to be an
uber pool with that [ __ ] you know but
uh thanks for calling brother homeward
my name is Alex and I was wondering if
there's any advice you could offer
regarding a loved one who sleeps loud
when I say that I mean he
snores and yells in his sleep at this
point anything helps okay so you got
that loud sleeper you know what I'm
saying
you got that [ __ ] Benjamin Barksdale
you got somebody being loud next to you
while you're trying to sleep first of
all that's insane do you know that
that's an early warning sign of insanity
somebody who when other people are
trying to sleep is is violent in their
sleep you know I'm saying I was eating
this girl she liked to wake up the
middle the night and catch a [ __ ]
handful of skittles in the FaceCam and
you know she wanted to eat skittles she
could keep a bowl of skittles by the bed
and just drop them a skittles into her
throat out of a dead sleep always
fighting in her sleep sweating it's wild
man it's wild you know Pete they got
some violent sleepers out there they got
[ __ ] people out there sleeping envy
I'm like damn where you sleeping in
Vietnam come baguette tighten up if he's
allowed shut him down put him in the
other room and I would also try them on
different sides of his body if he's loud
roll him on his side if he's loud again
roll him on the other side he's got four
sides try all four if he's violent maybe
tape his legs together tie his legs
together you know you can also try some
of that arm
Metamucil you know what I'm saying
Metamucil makes you have to go to the
bathroom and do number twos and if
you're on that Metamucil look you're not
gonna sleep real heavy because your
butthole is gonna be real alert because
dude look man your butthole gets alert
feel like your booty wants to whistle
but then it is it's number twos you're
doing number twos and so that Metamucil
will do that so maybe put them a little
bit of Metamucil but thank you for
calling there about that loud sleeper
man come on people sleep and [ __ ]
loudly get it together dude get it to
[ __ ] gather you were a loud sleeper
you [ __ ]
how much more selfish could you be
tell them to tighten up baby he tell
them I said it let's take another call
here this from George Davis hey Theo
this is George from Texas man I just
wanted to say thanks for all your
laughter you provide
it's really helping me get through a
tough time right now in my life are you
welcome George man you know it's the
least I can do man it says my service I
guess you know we're being a part of
this world and thank you for calling in
because this is us this is us man more
man see like a lot of other people I you
know work my ass off and trying to find
a place to buy and move into eventually
and it was a cabin up in southern
Colorado so oh you got that so cold
that's so cold a southern colorado cabin
huh mm-hmm
that sounds good dude I'll let a [ __ ]
carp jump in my just jumping them up one
of those sacks you catch them carp sex
and people catch exotic uh
mountain lions and [ __ ] out there and
you could hunt out there and you could a
lot of weird [ __ ] happen out there
people killing their spouses and stuff
like that people going missing just an
overall real you know people finding
treasure just an overall adventurous
area let's hear more just a good place
to get away from all the stress and
problems that come with living in the
big city but man all that [ __ ] changed
this weekend when some self-confessed
anarchists just burnt down the whole
[ __ ] forest 40,000 acres up in flames
they still don't have it contained right
now and damn brought in all that [ __ ]
what's happening they shouldn't sell
matches at gas stations I've been sayin
that [ __ ] how you selling matches right
next to [ __ ] gas bro you know I'm
saying I got anarchists out there
they should have anarchist tests test
people to see if they're [ __ ]
anarchists do when they're in high
school you know I'm saying give them a
match and give them a piece of cotton
and tell them do not like this piece of
cotton on fire if they do it do [ __ ]
lock them down or shut them down you
know I'm saying give him one of those
remote control scarfs and [ __ ] hell
shut him down let's hear more I mean
just thinking about all my neighbors had
lost their house and all the
firefighters and police you know that
are doing a good job to contain all that
[ __ ] and yeah fires dangerous dude fire
will [ __ ] you up dude fire can do all
kinds of stuff
fire can turn dough into a [ __ ]
muffin fire can make a biscuit fire can
light a hallway if I can burn down the
damn earth dude
homeward they arrested the guy and he's
in jail right now but man it's just been
a really tough time and your comedy your
style of humor really helps me get
through it I've been thinking about it a
lot listening to the podcast and man it
makes me feel like I'm hanging out with
one of my older cousins from Oklahoma
you know they're always funny and had
that kind of same view on life that you
do so well thank you man I appreciate
you saying that George you know you know
I I'm glad if I can be that sometimes
like an escape or something or a change
of pace man I'm happy too you know
that's nice you to say man because that
makes me feel like I'm doing something
positive you know and I think all of us
you know all we really wanted our chorus
to is to feel like we are making
somebody else feel good you know I think
really at our core that all I want is
just to is to do that you know I think
we all want to do that I mean you got me
getting the emotional here a little bit
man yeah it makes me when you said that
it made me feel you just made me feel
something I'm trying to figure out what
it is you made me feel like I was doing
something for somebody else I guess or
you made me feel like I've service or
you made me feel like I had some
importance like not in a selfish way but
just that I was doing something not for
myself and and I appreciate that man
that made me feel good when you said
that so thank you George bro and you'd
be safe out there dude stay out the fire
you know I'm saying stay out that don't
buy a kerosene coat from nobody we won't
see you again but if you want to
kerosene coat you probably get one
here in China dude you know I'm saying
bro you could get a butt plug that's
made out of bubblegum son it's gonna be
bad breath all month after that [ __ ]
wild night thank you for calling George
let's have another call here this came
in from the library's fan line you can
uh you can find these or video you can
see these now on on youtube you can see
these calls as they come in it's not
just the voicemails anymore you can see
the live raised ones and you can also
submit videos through our website Theo
van comm click on the podcast link and
you can submit a video there a video
question and and that is all free here
we go I was just talking to my
girlfriend about what it is that I like
about you and your act - I'd say thank
you and this is a call from Darren
Henderson and Darren Henderson as a
person here we go it's that you seem
like that you haven't lost a sense of
wonder that almost every child has and
that's what I like about you that's what
I decided so I wanted to thank you for
that
and sure I realize that's not a question
but I'm just running that by you I
wanted to get a response from you either
way thanks Darren that's nice you to say
man you know I remember on us on a class
trip to Disney World when I was young
and we honestly I'll be honest with you
eat some LSD and we [ __ ] do we saw it
all son I'm saying I saw man I saw
people and some machines and I saw it
all dude and I saw a great bird come out
of the far north and man he had [ __ ]
strong hands and I saw him [ __ ] touch
my eyeballs with his fevery [ __ ]
feelings but um
sorry but let me get this back to you so
anyway I was at Disney World and uh and
they have their on a wall I said
imagination is more important than
knowledge and I I think it's a quote
from Einstein or something I'm not sure
but I just remembered seeing that and I
got my picture taken next to it now
that's a popular quote but I just knew
that that was just my life man that that
you know I think when I was young I just
hated like I think sadly when a certain
point I hated my life so much I hated
myself for I don't know what it was you
know I just was not this did not feel
good when I was young and I just heard a
lot man I don't know what you know I
just I don't know and I'm not sad about
it I'm not you know it's the past you
know I can't live there that shit's over
I'm not living there anymore but but my
imagination I just needed it and so I
think God gave me an imagination just
because I needed it man you know I just
hated being inside of myself I just
hated I just didn't have any tools to
feel okay and so it was just you know
and I said I saw I think God gave me
that he gave me a sense of wonder and a
sense of imagination but yeah I remember
he said imagination is more important
than knowledge and I just loved that and
and I remember telling my teacher that
one time he said you're gonna fail I
said imagination is more important than
knowledge he goes well you you're gonna
fail this test and he goes you got a D
and I said well I'm gonna imagine that I
didn't get a D and that was it but yeah
but thanks for saying that dude I guess
you know I think there's also a lot of
[ __ ] I don't know
so which is most stuff so it's like damn
I might always have a sense of wonder
dude until and unless I figure some more
stuff out but I appreciate you calling
man and just having me think about this
kind of stuff and think about like what
it is to wonder you know wondering is
like
sometimes I think like okay so I know
this you know I know like a shoe you
know I know it it's a shoe but then
sometimes it's like oh well it could be
a hard foot mitten you know it could be
a [ __ ] leather spatula that kind of
wraps around your foot a little bit you
know I thought about like I don't know I
like to just I don't know it's not brain
just serves things to me differently I
don't know
this is interesting a sense of wonder
you got me thinking about this now you
got me wondering about Wonderbra but
thanks for calling Darren I appreciate
that man and tell your girlfriend that
um that she has a boyfriend who likes to
think about stuff and that is of so much
value we are quickly quickly catapulting
in the two types of people in the world
people who are thinkers and people who
are not and it is happening I believe so
fast and and uh and it's I don't think
it ends well for people that aren't I
don't think it can let's hear another
call here we go I feel I'm Alex from
Idaho hey Alex thanks for calling in and
I'm calling because I just realized and
I'm not feeling very good about it
okay you just relapse and you're not
feeling really great about it thank you
for calling let's hear more I just shot
and I've been clean and sober for about
a month okay
well that's okay you know it's an is it
your you still here you have your voice
you're talking about it you're thinking
about it you know you're uh you're being
active let's hear more I'm kind of
feeling down right now see all right
there you're also right about it I'm
currently walking home from downtown
because I don't have my car well
probably good you don't have your car if
you drinking you know you know stay away
from that vehicle
I'm saying you want to be that killer no
crowd I'm not proud you know I'm so
proud and I I just wanted some advice I
want some good words from you okay well
you're not proud yeah well it's not a
thing of pride I mean you want to have
yeah I'm sorry you don't feel good about
it but it doesn't make you a bad person
because you did it you know you said yet
about six weeks that's a long time of
being sober if you want to be sober you
know and the good thing is you can
always start over you just start it over
now so it's okay you did six weeks
that's good man you did six weeks dude
my buddy robbed a bakery one time right
[ __ ] idiot
also you know just bake at home it takes
longer to make as much bread and stuff
but robbing a bakery is dumb but um they
gave he got six weeks he got six weeks
in a local jail so you know six weeks is
six weeks and don't feel bad about
yourself you can feel bad that this
didn't work out that this you know but
now you got six weeks and now you have a
challenge get more next time if you want
to get more you know and also it doesn't
sound like you're a bad person until you
didn't sound [ __ ] wasted yet a shot I
remember I'll try to go 31 days one time
in on thirty days a girl asking if I
wanted to drink and I had no defense if
a woman asked me for anything
I had no ability to stand on my own two
feet at all and I said yes and man I
didn't feel proud either I felt like I
gave up but Here I am a couple years
later and I got two years tomorrow so so
that's okay you know I'm saying we still
love you
keep your [ __ ] together you know I'm
saying just make sure you wash your
crotch up every now and then you know
and that doesn't that and that's mad
that's for everybody if you drink it or
not drink and wash your [ __ ] dick or
wash your crotch people thinking dude so
many people never wash their cross and
let the water run over everything don't
[ __ ] wash it wash your crotch
dude I met this girl at the library one
time and she only had eight she only had
eight fingers or eight toes I don't
remember which one it was but uh you
know she only had eighteen of the big
twenty and uh and her crotch Amboy I met
her at the library brought about her
that cross smelled like a [ __ ] card
catalogue dude you know what I'm saying
it smelled like do it do it do it do it
been deaths you know do we the decimals
he'd been decimated my like due he had
been decimated up in there
you got to tighten up your crotch no
matter what man or woman you know I'm
saying Sud you're nuts up
you want you want soap that can [ __ ]
predict the future bro wash your nuts
where they get a bar here from China
let's take one more call man and then I
gotta get I got to get off the line man
I got to get off the line it's just been
it's been a lot and we'll get more we
got a lot of calls that came in and
we'll get more but um let's take a call
right here this is says dark arts in
China here we go what's up Scott up in
West Virginia thanks for calling hope
this call reaches you before you take
your flight over see but too late Scott
but I'm glad you call it anyway and I'm
excited to hear it what is it I want to
rub one out you get caught up in the
dark arts of the Orient I don't know
what they are but they sound mysterious
and just a bit more dangerous to me you
might catch yourself with a pair of
chopsticks and get a splinter and that's
kind word it works itself out but
thinking you might want handle business
before you have business handles whoo
well I appreciate you looking out for me
man
you know and III you know I didn't hear
this call until now but I didn't do that
you know I'm saying I came up in here
fully chocked up you know I'm saying I
got these smut nuts are full of fully
sauced up you know I'm saying I'm
showing up with these I mean I could
probably sell one of my nuts for $1,000
a nut full of [ __ ]
fancy American straight-up human sauce
bro
that's a damn delicacy around here
everything's a delicacy
dude you could eat you know I'm saying
you could sell a doves [ __ ] to
somebody over here for probably $250 I
mean you could do anything you know like
they got all kinds of stuff here they
have any type of animal you can imagine
and I'm saying they got ostriches raised
on [ __ ] rare whale semen
they have ostriches that their whole
lives they've only been fed semen from
big whales and that meat my god that
meat is the meat from those ostriches
bro will crawl in your [ __ ] mouth and
sleep all night and then go down your
throat and that is damn I mean that is
the lord that is wild but yeah I didn't
do it man I came in here fully up and
I'ma leave fully up you know and it's
been a good experience and I didn't get
caught in cuz you can do all kinds up in
China you know I'm for the same for $60
you could jerk off into a shark's mouth
and sure it's just a dude dressed up
like a shark but still you know sure
it's just a dude named Larry shark but
still but I know anything can happen
around here man and and I appreciate you
looking out for me Scott but I made it
through so far and I still have a little
bit more time to kill here tomorrow but
uh but so far I have made it through
what else don't want to talk about um
what else what else is here ah not too
much man got some other dates out there
I want to tell you about Appleton
Wisconsin Salt Lake City Washington DC
all those things you can go get them
what else man any other big adventures
not much just taking it as it comes and
realizing that man is just so still so
much stuff I can do you know not being
hard on myself but just man life is such
a crazy challenge somebody sent me an
email and it said man Alyssa it said
imagine that you just exist
in nothing for eternity but your spirit
your energy just exists like and I'm
paraphrasing exists in eternity like out
in there in the ether and he said life
is life is the when you is a moment
where you get to come to the forefront
of the fishbowl of being and you get to
interact with the other with the other
spirits like life is that that's what
our lives are there's all these other
you know humans and beings and
everything out there in the ether in the
space and the all these other energies
and and life is this is this one is this
one time period where we get to show up
in a form and actually interact with
each other before we go back out into
the ether this is it this is it we get
to be here and feel and love and see and
hurt and recover and forgive we get to
be here man we are you are [ __ ] here
you might be at work right now you might
be wherever but you're on a [ __ ]
planet floating in the middle of space
and you get to love if you want to you
get to help if you want to you get to
forgive you get to apologize you get to
start over you get to make it to six
weeks sober if you want to you get to
learn a new language if you want you get
to travel to another within that this
this existence you can travel to another
type of people that speak a whole
different language and experience all
those feelings and emotions and a
moments in a different it with a little
bit of a different recipe man is
fascinating being alive we can't control
it
we can take it as it comes
we can control ourselves and I'm not
trying to preach or anything tonight but
I just I don't know I'm in China man and
I'm just you know my yang yang's is up
my yang yang's is up thank you guys so
much dude thank you guys so much thank
you for being here with me I'm just
grateful we got a lot more calls stuff
what to get to him later man because I
got you know I got to do to bed I got
and I got to edit all this and upload it
so it's gonna be a lot of effort but I'm
excited to put it in I'm excited to put
this effort in as always you can hit the
hotline if you have a comment a
suggestion ninety five six six four nine
five zero three follow us support I'll
see you in Raleigh North Carolina this
weekend you know and I love you and be
good yourself because because you
probably deserve it have you thought
about that you just might you're making
it you know that don't you you're making
it
[Music]
I've seen whole men about a hundred days
I can almost hear mama bleep for my
Restless soon and now he made a dollar
light spill but where it's going in
queue me and I still get wet I'm bound
go panis bishop gun
[Music]
bacon wrong come on you got this you're
making it you got this
got this [ __ ] today this week this month
got it
most all of my plans slip right through
my head my god next to me Pocono
if their spiral wasn't our glance I'm
slaving I'm about an hour
I'll shut it down
but how
[Music]
a good man is fan they get me man
[Music]
you got a guest you want to see on me
you go telling me
let's do this man
do this
[Music]
we can do this
next week um I feel like we can't but
right now I feel like we could
[Music]
but
[Music]
I think everybody in Shanghai they came
out man
you know to be in another country and
somebody comes from your home country
instead of wanting them to bring you
something and them and and me make them
feel a certain way they made me feel
comfortable they wanted me to be okay
man just great people great people out
here the Cinna these group they got this
this group out of your storm Brian and
Barney in that fancy weather man too
[Music]
that fancy [ __ ] weatherman bro that's
the wildness man that's the wildness you
guys be good to yourselves you probably
deserve it I will see you back in
America